Maronna Stefano's would be lost without
her cellphone
hers is an activist life always
networking explaining the situation on
the ground at the Freedom Forum in Oslo
heads of state and Nobel laureates are
speaking joining them is Estefan OHS she
speaks about her daily fight against
dictatorship and for the human rights of
refugees if a person is calling me from
libya egypt israel or somewhere else we
have representatives of the irritant
government that supposed to help these
people out but unfortunately our
government does not care so activists
like me we do the job that an ambassador
is supposed to do Maronna Stefano's has
been waiting three years for this moment
she's meeting her fellow countryman say
haya Stefano's the 19 year old has
finally found his way to Europe he says
that he fled Eritrea in 2012 to escape
the autocratic government its use of
torture and the threat of lifelong
military service it was not the life he
envisioned for himself he was captured
by Bedouins in Egypt and imprisoned in
one of their torture camps it was such a
hell I don't seen before like they were
new additive shock main things
is disgusting I don't want any members
Maronna Stefano's photographs and
documents the torture she records the
name of the victim and contacts family
members and she collects money for the
ransom
the kidnappers received almost twenty
thousand euros for say hi his release he
then traveled through Libya and Italy
until he made it to Norway the country
of his dreams
her work takes Estefan owes all over the
world to Israel to Sudan to the United
States she learns the routes taken by
refugees and finds out when ships
carrying them leave Libya for Europe at
home in Stockholm it is here that the 40
year old journalist meticulously
documents the details of a global
refugee crisis a call from an Eritrean
woman in trouble the woman managed to
escape her captors but is now stuck in
Sudan Maronna Stefano's hosts her own
show on radio Lorena is a station
broadcast by satellite to Eritrea where
listeners can hear updates on the status
of their family members at least for the
family if it said when somebody is
missing and then either we called and
that person is dead or that person is
our life it's a big thing for the family
fighting a dictatorship is difficult
scissor Stefano's but the real hero she
says are the refugees themselves